hey guys it's Greg it here
tell me kill trees on Instagram so many
people requested this I use I kind of
don't do all the game trails I like
watching the game trailers I just don't
feel like it can really make commentary
on them Tony's a gamer and I was like
he's dabbled with battlefront so yeah
might as well have him here to make this
a little more worth everyone's time not
really I mean no one's gonna get
partially true stars out front to you
first person request is fearless
Entertainment one of the most [ __ ]
channels I've ever seen
I've waited 30 years for me
[Music]
remember my last workers real
[Music]
rapping man to impress so everyone came
to Academy that's important that's the
point sergeant again
[Music]
by him
[Music]
no money ow
ho thousands actual game
Oh fighting Yoda story
[Music]
all right yeah oh she's gonna Kyla wish
I'm gonna put everybody in this man
there we go
I know I'll use rayon and [ __ ] dark
oh if that's true then hopefully you
just get every yea person start with the
Han Solo and Jar Jar Binks and whoever
Jimmy Smith's played an episode to you
three get some bubble fit just running
through [ __ ] that was really cool man I
was sick female protagonist to think the
Star Wars movies like to do now the Star
Wars loves their female protagonists I
talked about us limiting looking over
women are taking over women have always
ruled I mean just us men have it fear
them in the galaxy and that's why they
are in charge of the galaxy now the
story is really good at last one was
just like really for online play I felt
like but I mean what you run through the
story in this game all you're going to
want to do is online play I enjoyed that
but did you throw a little game player
yeah I really just want to see how it's
going to like looks like yes is your to
the gameplay I'm into like the cinema
clips the most the stories are always
good in my one every kind of game coming
in and out like just graphic watch
everything's like looks like that when
you're like in cutscenes they put a
really good story into this one man it's
just gonna be like run through that [ __ ]
really quick and just play online oh
yeah the last one they let you play out
as a couple characters but this one it
looks like they're gonna just let you go
throughout a lot of the Star Wars like
even it even to get stories that they
could tell like how they wanted to grow
one if you could just like implement
that into these games yeah it's just
like you could just have the whole world
where it almost feels like you're
watching the movies but then you
actually get to get the gameplay like
get to play through the levels where
they like killing bunch of people shoot
like stormtroopers but actually you know
you know but I feel like I can say about
this we've seen the battlefront footage
of why I'm drawn to it in terms of its
of where its story is taking place you
know when you see kylo Ren
and Darth Maul all these different
characters and the time frame of saving
places it's like it puts you in the
actual Wars of Star Wars I love the
movies and the movies though they don't
really go into like the Wars of [ __ ]
yeah that's why I like wrote one a lot
because I felt it was like a war movie
in a way and here's like yeah you're
going into the wars you're experiencing
the battle the unknown battles we didn't
get a seed going on all this or this the
battles are treating you can get into
Darth Maul fighting ham Yoda obi-wan
Kenobi Anakin you know it takes place
around you know and it starts off with
and did that soar blows up and yeah it
was from the first movie so seeing like
we're stock where the wars were taking
place it's cool to actually be involved
in the wars and see the cannon I think
this is cannon I'm not sure don't quote
me on that Amy if you want or forgive me
if you can write not it's this really
cool fanfiction in the movies you get
the story but it on this when you get to
like see like the whole bad crazy after
the last one that was it like how you
felt about it but you really didn't have
like a really good story to like hold it
down like that I start we're putting in
the Star Wars Battlefront to the new
console but ii was like okay now we're
gonna have a great story you're going to
like get to see what happened during
this time line during yeah i'm line
first opera was definitely a financial
success and but i know some people were
kind of let down by it i heard how that
was seemed really divisive and how it
seemed likely to play for a while but it
was almost like you got a Call of Duty
Star Wars but I mean when you don't like
put so much of like that Star Wars like
storylines into like a game it's just
like okay I'm just basically using this
for multiplayer but this one is just
like there we have the engine so they
just put so much more story and a lot
like I hope it they put a lot of cool at
a little mini game plays are mini games
into it so you could just like really do
a lot of different things than just a
straight multiplayer team deathmatch or
something like that but it's always been
fun man like this first even when you
play it on PlayStation 2 just to always
be in the whole war it just feels like
you're playing battlefield but with Star
Wars
yeah fulfil of it and if you could just
like have that space battle that should
be
oh good that's why I felt like they
showed a little bit of gameplay when
they're showing like a fighter jet
flying because I was like maybe you
could actually like let's have a look
when you're flying in the game so that's
where like most excited for you don't
have some space so all right well thank
you for all you guys referring this hour
way I would have just watched this on my
own without a camera recording but you
guys wanted it like back in the day kind
of [ __ ] no man now you got to record
yourself watching video if you didn't
record it it's kind of like you never
watched it and then a lot of people are
going to go sit that is evidence before
there'll be a time where they'll allow
me to do reactions inside the actual
movie theaters hey you can subscribe to
the rail rejects that we create
strangely on Instagram tell me you'll be
streaming on Twitch it's in the gamer
that's going to be the duty straight out
why she streams on Twitch once you want
you ever mention it
I barely started doing Fitness [ __ ]
mention it next time what's your twitch
account I'm it's in the game it's in the
gamer it's in the game going to switch